I've been thinking about this a lot in
the last couple of weeks this notion of
giving up so you would think that
evolutionarily the most um
adaptive way of being is that you go you
you you fight as long as you physically
can and then when you can't you can't
and there's in there's this Photograph
there's some videos you can find of
insects crawling around where like you
know this like like most of it is
already gone and it's still sort of
crawling you know like
um a Terminator style right like as far
as as long as you physically can you
keep going
mammals don't do that so so a lot of
mammals including rats have this thing
where when when they think it's it's a
hopeless situation they literally give
up and die when physically they could
have kept going I mean humans certainly
do this and there's there's some like
really unpleasant experiments that the
the this guy forget his name did with
them drowning rats where if he where
where rats normally drown after a couple
of minutes but if you teach them that if
you just tread water for a couple of
minutes you'll get rescued they can
tread water for like an hour and so
right and so they literally just give up
and die and so evolutionarily that
doesn't seem like a good strategy at all
evolutionarily seems why would you like
what's the benefit ever of giving up you
just do what you can and you know one
time out of a thousand you'll actually
get rescued right but this issue of of
of actually giving up suggests some very
interesting metacognitive controls where
you've now gotten to the point where
survival actually isn't the top drive
and that for whatever you know there are
other considerations that have like
taken over and I I think that's uniquely
a mammalian thing but um I don't know
yeah the Camus
the existentialist question of Why Live
just the fact that humans commit suicide
is a really fascinating question from an
evolutionary perspective and what was
the first and that's the other thing
like what is the simplest uh system
whether whether evolved or you know
natural or whatever that is able to do
that right like you can think you know
what other animals are actually able to
do that I'm not sure maybe
you could see animals over time for some
reason lowering the value of survive at
all costs gradually until other
objectives might become more important
maybe I don't know how evolutionarily
how that how that gets off the ground
that just seems like that would have
such a strong pressure against it you
know
just imagine a you know a population
with with with with a lower
um you know with if you were a mutant in
a population that had less of a uh less
of a survival imperative would you would
your genes outperform the others it
seems no is there such a thing as
population selection because maybe
suicide is a way
uh for organisms to decide that
themselves that they're not fit for the
environment somehow yeah that's a that's
a really uh country you know population
level selection is a is a kind of a deep
controversial area but it's tough
because on the face of it if that was
your genome it wouldn't get propagated
because you would die and then your
neighbor who didn't have that would have
all the kids it feels like there could
be some deep truth there that we're not
understanding